Today,
I'm going to talk about a censorship
in the United States since 1945 in the
period that we're studying.
Um,
and I'm going to connect that with
the human stain and some of my general
thoughts about Roths work, uh,
at the very end of lecture.
So I'll give you a little
bit of history and,
and then a little bit
of meditation on Roth.
I asked you for today to go around to
the various bookstores in new haven,
choose one and go and observe
what you saw there. In particular.
I asked you to think about what
you are not seeing there. Um,
so does anyone want to tell me what they
saw on their little observation trip?
What did you observe?
Yes,
I went to the library
and a ton of history,
history being cultural studies both
upfront and that seemed like very
deliberately, uh, actually,
uh, diverse in what way?
Like diverse culturally as in time.
As far as the,
as far as history goes to the Ida,
I looked at the end of the range.
Everything from Germany
during the Weimer Republic,
like a history of like tragedy potential
or some top title like that too.
Um, you know, death and the Atlantic
slave trade to mean all of, all of his,
but other, mainly you're
syndicates, but yeah,
not there.
It's interesting.
I looked for specifically because I
thought that we be, there was my comp.
Did you look back in the stacks to uh Huh.
I didn't see it there. Elaborate on.
So I guess they don't support it.
I approve it.
They go, you, you approve of mine. Calm
for not being in, in labyrinth bookstore.
That's right. Again, I
guess one cup can be a risk.
Very good. Okay. What else?
What else do people notice?
Did you notice about the bookstore?
Yes.
Graduate.
Which bookstore did you go to?
Okay,
great.
By Yale graduates. But here's a
question, not by your professors.
It's a significant difference.
Um, what else did you notice? Yes,
local market.
What else did you notice?
Yes. You like, I guess, uh, that, um,
I really hadn't thought
about this as much,
but how much or how much would this
isn't is to decide what kind of shelf the
book goes in? Yes. Like history versus
philosophy and ice. It's probably the
polishers do you do that or I don't know.
Well, this is a really important
question where to shelve the book.
Now it's not just about categories,
although it is partly about categories.
What subject matter does a book belong to?
It's also about what
kind of shelf physically.
So those tables, uh, that, you know,
we're thinking about in labyrinth
with that array of literature.
Who chose that? Does anyone know who chose
that? Let her try to put on that table.
I can tell you in a minute. Uh,
one question is who chose that?
Now those tables are in
Barnes and noble too.
So you walk in into the bookstore on
the ground level and they're all those
tables and the stacks go up really high.
There are all these elaborate ways
of getting books covers to face you.
Okay?
Then there are all the stacks and shelves
up on the upper level and those books
are interspersed with smaller displays.
So if you go up there,
you'll begin to see some very interesting
things. There's a little table,
for example,
up on the right,
if you notice this right as you come up
the stairs in Barnes and noble and it
usually has it's,
it's uh,
promoted as like urban
literature. Well, it's really, uh,
in my experience having seen
it over the years, it's really,
it's just like code for
black writers somehow. Um,
so it's all these books about the black
history of new haven or whatever. Um,
so you have these little
tables around now,
the big tables in front of Barnes and
noble, who chooses what goes on there.
That space is bought and
paid for by publishers,
bought and paid for.
It's part of the contract with the
publisher to stock that book that it be
displayed in certain ways.
You know,
those Nice discounts that you get 20%
off the New York Times bestseller books
when they're in hardback.
Those are possible at Barnes and noble
because of the huge buying power of that
bookstore.
So they buy in huge volume.
Now a store like labyrinth or its
predecessor Brookhaven wasn't able to have
that kind of volume in sales and so they
couldn't negotiate with the publisher
that sort of discount.
So that means that a smaller bookstore,
because of its smaller buying power,
can't provide a competitive price in a
market where Barnes and nobles right next
door.
Now,
there were ways that independent
bookstores try to compensate for that,
especially in this market.
Um,
by giving discounts to faculty members
stocking their books at the bookstore.
This is somewhat controversial,
although it's Barnes and noble that
has tried to make it controversial, um,
by bringing it up with
the university and saying,
now isn't this a kind of bribery?
But that's the way that a store
like labyrinth or like Brookhaven,
before it was able to try to be priced
competitive among people it knew,
wanted to buy from them,
those professors who stock their
book at an independent bookstore.
So back to this question of who decides
what's on the table at labyrinth?
I went in and I said, who decides
what's on this table? And they said, oh,
she's over there.
And I went and talked to her and I said,
how do you decide what's on the
table? She said, well, you know,
I had a good general education,
uh, as a young person.
And I kind of know who's who in the
intellectual circles in Europe and in the
United States.
And so I browse the lists and I talked
to sales rep when they come in and I read
and I look at what certain
courses or stalking, um,
and I see what people
are reading on campus.
And the night aside has really different
from that space being bought and paid
for by a publisher as part
of a marketing agreement.
Those tables are very powerful in four
browsers in shaping what browsers might
possibly by or think about when
they come into a bookstore.
So that space is particularly key to
a bookstore presence culturally in the
community.
And uh,
Sarah's point about the Yale
graduates on the bookshelf,
that is a nod to Barnes and nobles,
immediate context.
So there is that local marketing piece.
But think about this.
There are just a few fiction buyers
who work with publishers to decide what
novels will be in Barnes and noble.
So writers,
when they're thinking about,
can I sell my book instead of thinking,
I wonder if I can impress
the owner of the seminary,
Co op in Hyde Park in
Chicago, very famous, huge,
wonderful bookstore, not a chain.
Instead of saying, you know,
I want to sell my book in Chicago, it's
set there and maybe it'll be appealing.
I wonder if I can impress the owner of
that bookstore and having a strategy that
addresses those kinds of individual
circumstances in different spaces. Um,
Powells in Seattle,
labyrinth in New York. Um,
they have to say,
I wonder if I can impress the
buyer from Barnes and noble.
So instead of many people making that
decision about whether or novel is worthy
of being promoted,
it's one person.
That person becomes extremely powerful
in shaping what literary texts reach us,
what comes to our attention
through the bookstore. Now,
have you ever wondered as
you're driving down the street,
why there might be a Dunkin donuts here
and a Dunkin donuts just like two blocks
away.
Have you ever noticed that there are
various stores that you'll see this gas
station,
sometimes fast food restaurants,
sometimes Walmart bookstores or another
that you will sometimes see this.
Why is that?
Well,
what they're doing is competing in an
overwhelming way with another store in
that market.
Usually this happens when they're trying
to drive another store out of business.
So there are big enough chain they can
absorb losses from an unproductive second
store to saturate a market and then they
can absorb the closing of that second
store once the competitor has
been driven out of business.
So that's why that market
saturation happens.
It's not because they think it's going
to be profitable that there's another,
you know, hundred percent increase
when they add that second store,
one block over. It's, it's
all about market saturation.
It's getting it as close to a
hundred percent as possible.
So those kinds of tactics are possible
for chain stores and they are not
possible for independent bookstores.
And this is how many independent
bookstores have been, uh, have, have,
have been taken off the map in
our cities and in the suburbs.
So this is one way that
censorship comes to us,
not in that old fashioned
way of censorship laws,
but in a new way.
Markets Censorship.
This is always been part of how
things work in a capitalist economy.
It's true that in the past
literary enterprises be they
selling books or writing
books or publishing books had to make
a profit in order to stay afloat.
But the way that profit was made has
changed from the early 20th century until
this point.
And I'm going to say more about that.
So just by going into the bookstore,
I want you to think about
the next time you go in,
think about how things are
being presented to you. Now.
How many of you get most of the
books you buy? Not For classes?
Well, let's just ask this blanket
and then I'll break it down.
How many of you get most of the
books you buy, um, from a bookstore?
Still? Quite a few of you. How many of
you get the mostly over the Internet?
Okay. Not, not a majority. Um,
taking out classes,
books you buy for pleasure,
your own decision to buy them.
How many of you are still buying
those in bookstores? Okay.
Actually a lot of you so that,
that really even tips the
scale in favor of bookstores.
So That's interesting to me. I
wasn't sure what you would say, um,
that suggest that bookstores are
still powerful purveyors of culture.
They still shape what you
think about and what you read.
It's browsing or maybe that you've read
about something and you go looking for
it. Um, that brings
you into the bookstore.
Okay.
Censorship does have a legal
history in this part of the century.
And so now I want to
just give you a little
rundown of that.
So this is,
this is actually a title of
a chapter of a book that I,
I will be writing on the post 45 novel
and I'm going to have this as the last
chapter of that book.
Um,
the reason for that is that censorship
and what I'm calling to censure,
that's the public outcry against
literature, even not on legal grounds,
um, is a way for the culture
to speak back to the literary.
So I spend a lot of time in this class
and in my teaching in general and in my
writing talking about
what books say to us,
but what do we say back to those
books as a, as a society? Well,
censorship and, and it's,
it's companion censure. Uh,
do a lot of that talking back.
Yeah.
So there are two sides
of access to literature.
I've just been talking a little bit
about market constraints on what can be
published and read.
And now I'm going to talk a little
bit about legal constraints.
I'm going to get back to the market
constraints in a little while.
Yeah.
Since the early 20th century,
a lot of the legal constraints on
publishing and distributing, um,
literature have east in the 1870s,
the Comstock laws in the United States
aim to regulate the use of the males for
the, the um, uh,
for the dissemination of
obscene materials. This,
these laws were used in 1914 to indict
Margaret Sanger for sending information
about contraception across state lines
and she had to flee and she left the
country, uh, to protect herself.
So just the description of
how contraception worked, uh,
was a violation of the Comstock laws.
So of course we're happily out of that
moment in 1933 for literature was a major
decision by Judge Woolsey declaring
the James Joyce's Ulysses,
not obscene.
Um,
often censorship in literature would
have to do with the import of literature
into the United States.
So this is sort of on the same
logic as the Comstock laws.
Comstock laws regulate the traveling of
obscene literature, Cross state lines,
customs regulations,
regulated obscenity coming
into the United States.
Why is obscenity important?
Well,
obscenity is largely a recognized by
legal scholars as not being protected by
the 14th amendment.
It is not protected speech.
So that's why it was important for
someone who wanted to keep Ulysses out of
American hands to call it obscene.
Now,
it's very interesting to read
what Woolsey says about Ulysses.
It just shows you how the learned reading
of literature comes to have a legal
impact in the world.
So this is Woolsey on Joyce.
Joyce has attempted,
it seems to me with astonishing success
to show how the screen of consciousness
with it's ever shifting kaleidoscopic
impressions caries as it were on a plastic
Pallium c'est not only what is in the
focus of each man's observation of the
actual things about him,
but also on a penumbral zone.
Residual of past impressions,
some recent and some drawn
up by association from the
domain of the subconscious
is telling you about the
stream of consciousness,
method of narration and Ulysses.
Okay.
He shows how each of these impressions
affect the life and the behavior of the
character, which he is describing
it. I'm going to skip down. Um,
he goes on to to detail more
about Joyce's technique.
It is because Joyce has been loyal to
his technique and has not funked it's
necessary implications,
but has honestly attempted to tell fully
what his characters think about that.
He has been the subject of so many
attacks and that his purpose has been so
often misunderstood and misrepresented.
So here Woolsey takes a very serious
view of Joyce's artistic project and he
takes as the mark of its success,
what he calls the loyalty of Joyce to
that project of showing exactly what
characters think in their subconscious
associations as those rise into
consciousness and into language.
That principle is,
um,
is furthered in the
United States in 1957 with
a case called Roth. Um,
it's, let me get the,
it's Wroth v United States.
And
in this,
in this case,
Woolsey's approach to the literary is
enshrined in American Law affirmed as a
precedent.
So according to the Roth case,
something can be judged obscene
only if it meets three conditions.
And those are these,
the books,
descriptions of nudity or sex must go
beyond the limits of taste established by
community standards.
So that phrase,
community standards will become
very important in later law.
Know mentioned how in a minute
it must not appeal to the
interest of the average adult.
So yeah,
you have to be really abberant
in order to meet this standard.
It can't appeal to the
interest of the average adult.
That's what makes it obscene.
So I dunno necrophilia maybe that counts.
And lastly,
this is the kicker.
It must have no redeeming social
or literary value whatsoever.
That means if you can prove just that one,
you're safe.
So no matter what it is,
even if it is necrophilia,
if you can prove that
it has literary value,
it cannot be obscene.
Okay.
And so this particular standard
comes into play when, um,
Allen Ginsberg's howl goes on trial
and I think it's 1959 it goes on trial.
Similarly, accustomed case, uh,
or, and a case about selling,
uh,
the book,
it was bought at city lights bookstore
in San Francisco and the poor sales clerk
was indicted for selling it.
Uh,
and also the bookstore was
indicted for importing it.
It had been published in Europe.
Um,
all they had to do in that trial, and
it's very funny to read the transcript,
is to prove that Ginsburg in Howell
was doing anything remotely resembling
literary work.
And it's very funny to see people
trying to argue that he was not. Um,
so it's, it's not enough to say that
he uses the word cock, for example,
in that poem, that's not
enough. And they try to, the DA,
the prosecutor tries to make the case
on the basis of individual words.
And then you see them having
these hilarious conversations
about how individual
words work in metaphors and uh, how
they, how they mean different things.
This standard really saves literature
from any kind of legal continuing legal
censorship.
But there are other ways of,
uh,
producing century censorship
that community standards
comes to be a problem in,
for example,
textbook design.
So there are these huge markets in
public schools in Florida and Texas and
California.
And so textbook publishers have to appeal
to the community standards of those
huge,
powerful markets.
And that has an impact on what's
available to school systems all over the
country.
So there is a way that
those community standards,
while in the Roth case there a redeeming,
they help to make the case
against censorship against
a two wide definition of
obscenity.
It does have an impact in other ways
in the opposite direction in the,
since the 1990s in the
wake of these changes, um,
libraries have become the primary
place where legal cases are based.
So in 1982,
the school board of Long Island, uh, in,
in island trees as long island tries
to remove or actually does remove black
boys slaughterhouse five,
um,
and various other sort
of books of the 1960s,
mainly about,
um,
politics mostly has them
removed from the school library.
And as soon as brought against
that school system for doing that,
the decision in that case affirms that
even though public school systems are
within their rights in the context of
the classroom to restrict what is on the
syllabi of their teachers,
that the school library represents
what they call special environment.
The special environment is
a place of voluntary study.
It is a place where the 14th
amendment cannot be suspended.
And as they say,
sort of poetically,
students do not leave their
rights at the school door.
And so school libraries can't
be regulated in that way,
but these things come up over and over.
And what's interesting about
that particular case is
that the objection was that
these books were anti American.
How far have we come since
black boy had to be truncated,
not that far in certain sectors of the
country, in certain ways of thinking,
black boy was cut in half because it
didn't seem like a good reflection on
America.
It's still a problem for some
books and being accepted and red.
So I began to talk market constraints
and I want to just say a little bit more
about that and how it affects the writing
of literature and the publishing even
before you arrive at the bookstore.
Um,
traditional publishing has gone,
undergone a huge
consolidations since the 1980s.
So there are large multinational
corporations that have
bought up publishers.
The one,
um,
signal example of this is when Bertelsmann
a German company bought up pantheon
books. Um, this is written about, uh,
in a book. Now I'm forgetting the
name of it. Um, it'll come to me.
Um,
one of the Pantheon editors led
a revolt when this happened.
It became clear that
Bertelsmann was going to impose a
new standard of profitability on
the lists in Pantheons uh,
portfolio.
So it used to be in old time publishing
sort of mid century publishing and up to
the 1980s that the list
of literature list,
and that's the list of books
that any publisher publishes,
the list should be profitable.
That does not mean that every single
item on that list will be profitable.
So add utters in the old time mode could
work with writers who they found to be
difficult,
interesting.
Pathbreaking unusual,
not catering to what was popular.
They could work with writers and cultivate
them and they knew that they were
taking on a book,
say it's a collection of short stories.
These are notoriously hard to sell.
They were taking on a book that
was not going to make a profit,
but then they would also
take on the joy of cooking
or the joy of sex since it's censorship
day and they knew that the profit from a
popular book could help to carry and
balance those less profitable books or not
at all profitable books
that they had on the list.
So there was a management of lists that
could be tilted to allow different kinds
of books into the public domain.
When
publishers were taken over
by multinational corporations
that were very distant
from the in interaction
between an editor and a writer,
they looked at the numbers and they
started to demand that every book have its
profit loss analysis and that a very
strict regulation be followed in ensuring
that all titles,
we're going to make a profit.
That's a very different standard and
it had a huge impact on how editors,
what kind of latitude editors
had in working with writers
who they thought might
be a little unusual or not so marketable.
At the same time,
agents began to have a role in the
publishing business in the 1950s when at a
ters we're encouraging
literary writers directly.
They had a much more collaborative
relationship with writers,
but as profit became more important,
writers needed to turn to someone else
who wasn't going to pressure them to
follow the market and
agents came to have a role.
Now it's interesting,
there's yet a third role, um,
that has just begun to emerge in,
in this structure and that
is of the of the coach,
the writing coach.
So you can now pay big
bucks if you're a writer,
to have someone who will call
you up every week and say, hey,
how's the book going? Let's talk about
your ideas. Are you writing today?
It used to be that agents
took that kind of active role.
Will agents are very busy now with their
clients selling movie rights and such
things. Movie rights are where
a lot of the profit in a,
in a book sale come from.
Yeah.
So agents began to be what
the old time editor was.
And I think we have yet to see whether
coaches become what agents used to be in
turn,
but as profitability becomes more and
more of an issue in selling a book to a
publisher,
there's an ever ongoing search for
that person who will be the ally of the
literary in this process.
Okay.
I've talked about the consolidation and
bookselling the rise of the chains and
I've also talked about those financial
relationships between booksellers and
publishers where spaces bought.
They also have incentives, um,
that publishers give sometimes give
money for readings to be held at a
bookstore. So, so sometimes those things
are bought also who's kinds of events,
promotional events.
There is of course,
this whole context of the rise of the
Internet and all kinds of competition from
the film industry.
Other media.
Yeah.
Market constraints are
sometimes a paradoxically produced
by that overload that we get from the
intranet.
So yeah.
What that means is the culture
is finding new arbitrators.
So you have this huge volume
of information and cultural
offerings being given
to you.
Okay.
In that welter of information,
we all look to some arbiter to
tell us how do I sort this out?
Nobody has the time to read all the blogs
and decide which one they're going to
read regularly.
So you might get a link from someone
else's page, someone you are friends with,
someone you admire, a writer
you've seen elsewhere. Um,
you might read certain print publications
and from there follow them into the
Internet,
into cyberspace.
Most books now come with a web address
somewhere on them. A lot of films do.
Most films do.
Okay.
This is still in a,
in a period of development.
How profit gets connected up with
those arbitrators isn't yet very clear.
So companies are experimenting
with paying for placements.
You know like when you do the Google
search and there are certain Google
sponsored links at the top,
that's like having the space in the
front of your store bought and paid for.
So you think that you're getting,
or I think we all know that
those are sponsored links now,
but at the beginning people
didn't really quite know that.
So it looked like you were getting the
product of a disinterested electronic
search,
but in fact you are getting a promotion.
So the intranet experiments
with all kinds of uh,
both new and tried and true ways of using
money to create prominence among the
welter of information.
Then there is another rising problem
in question and that is of intellectual
property in access as books are digitized.
So I don't know if you have heard of
the Google book project and also all the
digital libraries initiatives.
There are, there are various ones,
but the Google book project is,
I'm digitizing with a special technology.
People think it's probably
a robotic technology.
It's kept secret for scanning books that
are in the public domain and they've
made agreements with lots of university
libraries, including Stanford, Cornell,
Michigan,
to digitize all the books that are
beyond the copyright that are in their
collections to make a
huge digital library.
And the dream is that this will
be a sort of bonanza of access.
It'll be searchable, it'll
be fine. Well maybe free.
It'll be accessible all the world.
So there is a dream here that's very noble
publishers.
And writers groups.
Unions are very worried about copyright
infringement because Google has stepped
over the line and is interested in
pushing the envelope into scanning
copyrighted material.
So what has started to happen is that
individual publishers have made deals with
Google
to let Google digitize
their list for a fee.
But see now that money starts
to come into this arrangement,
it starts to look less like free access
and more like an access that is once
again shaped by these
financial considerations.
It's not at all clear how the nobility
of the project and the financial context
are going to work themselves out.
And it's not at all clear yet what
the general approach of educational
institutions will be towards this. Yale
has not signed on to this, for example.
So some universities have, some
haven't. These are huge, uh,
looming questions that will impact
what we get to see as literature.
Um,
how much access we have among the vast
choices that the Internet makes available
to us.
Um,
I want to just mention one more thing
and that's about internationalization.
One thing that,
um,
you didn't probably see the
bookstore is fiction and translation,
contemporary fiction in translation,
notoriously impossible to sell.
Um,
there is a press called the new press
that was founded after some of the
Pantheon editors left. And, uh,
they founded this nonprofit press
that is the only kind of fiction that
the new press publishes contemporary
fiction in translation because they
knew that only a nonprofit press could
publish this,
it will never sell.
One of the objections to the Google book
project is that the vast majority of
its texts are in English.
And it seems to present an English
centric vision of the world's knowledge
because it does have pretensions to be
the repository of the world's knowledge
in the reception of literature.
There are other forces.
And here's when we start to move
into the realm of the human stain.
In the 1990s,
there was a very lively and often
acrimonious debate in academia and,
uh,
among intellectual commentators about
whether literature was the purveyor of
ideology, political
ideology. So the question is,
does literature have a message
that it's trying to tell us?
And one way to think about this is to
think about English one 25 major British
poets, the sort of, uh,
the picture of what the old
fashioned Canon might look like.
It's all white guys.
I think there might be one woman that you
can put on the syllabus in the spring,
a modern poet.
You can probably teach bishop.
I think people do teach bishop in
the second term of English one 25.
Did those poets represent the
communication of an ideology?
Because a lot of contemporary fiction
became the object of contention along with
these very traditional syllabi.
Are you going to include Toni
Morrison on your syllabus? Well,
this is no longer controversial.
She's such an overwhelmingly powerful
author at this time by the sheer quality
of her work.
But at her early in her career,
it would have been a question.
One of the striking things of course
about American fiction in the second half
of the 20th century into the 21st is
the demographic really does change.
Writers of color are much
more prominent there.
There are many more points of
view present in that Canon.
Okay.
So his literature,
sociology is sociological.
Does it speak to society
or is it an aesthetic, uh,
an aesthetic object?
Something that we should understand
as part of the history of an art form?
Do you have to choose between
these two? And I cite here, uh,
what became an incredibly important
book. It's really a wonderful book. Um,
by actually a Yale
graduate, John Guillory, uh,
title is cultural capital,
the problem of literary Canon Formation
Publish right at the height of the
culture wars of the cannon wars.
Um,
in it he argues that in
the mid 20th century,
literature was a kind
of social elite good.
And that the aesthetic,
if it had an ideology,
it was an ideology of bourgeois privilege.
So it wasn't that the content of
particular poems would be communicating
something about an elite
bourgeois ideology,
but rather that the very act of being
in the institution where you would study
such a thing at Yale in English one 25,
that was the repository of the
elite power of these texts.
So it had much more to do
with institutions than it
did about the content of any
particular literary work.
And he makes them very persuasive readings
of canonical poems that demonstrate
the undecidability of their ideology or
the way that they resist how they'd been
cast,
how those poems had been cast by critics.
There are also ways that novels were
received and complained about that become
part of this picture.
So we've talked about black boy.
I mentioned how how controversial woman
warrior was because of its impurity as a
Chinese text.
Um,
Toni Morrison became a real advocate of
writing by women of color in particular
and also as a literary critic.
She mounted an argument about
how whiteness functions as a,
uh, a central part of the
traditional Canon of literature.
And she wrote playing in
the dark whiteness and the
literary imagination in 1992
very influential text
internationally.
We had the phenomenon of Selman.
Rusty's Rusty's persecution.
The fatwah issued against
him by the Ayatollah Khomeini
after the publication of
the say tannic versus for
its depiction of Islam.
That kind of persecution becomes,
uh,
a feature of this more internationalized
debate about what is okay to say,
especially about religions.
And then of course,
we have the Danish cartoon episode with
the cartoons of Mohammed that are now
seemingly it's resurgent.
There's another question about
a film about Mohammad's life,
I believe it is.
Then there's Roths work.
And here's where I just want
to meditate for a minute.
On Roth Philip Roth's work has been
defined by these kinds of objections that
censure that I was
talking about. He was, um,
very widely acclaimed in 1960 when goodbye
Columbus won the national book award.
Goodbye Columbus is a set
of stories mostly about, um,
young Jewish protagonists living in a
Jewish context in Jewish communities in
Newark or in New York.
It included a story called the conversion
of the Jews in which a young boy,
uh, actually it was a little older
than young boy. Maybe he's a teenager.
Ozzy Friedman becomes extremely agitated
because all his questions to his family
and to his rabbi about
Christianity are dismissed.
He finally comes to be punished for
asking these kinds of questions.
So Ozzy stages,
his revolt by climbing to the top of the
synagogue roof and threatening to jump
off if his family,
all the assembled students from his
school and the rabbi won't kneel down and
pray to Jesus, which of course they
do because it's about to jump off.
This story was quite controversial,
uh,
as you might imagine.
So there was a taste of Roths,
um, vexed relationship to
Jewish community in that story.
So it was all about how a hidebound
Jewish community was preventing and,
and circumscribing the curiosity
of a young American boy.
And it really highlighted
Ozzie's Americanness and
Roth has always emphasized
that about himself. He's
an American writer. Um,
like Saul bellow before him,
Saul Bellow had been his mentor and
teacher for a brief time at the University
of Chicago. Bellow insisted on
bringing into American literature.
The voice and Sensibility of an
immigrant Jewish family bellow was,
uh,
from a Russian Jewish family
that emigrated to Canada
in the early 20th century.
Bellow was told he would never,
because of his heritage,
when he was at the University of Chicago,
he was told he would never have the ear
for language that would allow him to
write beautifully because of
his linguistic background.
And because he was Jewish,
well bellow pioneered the way of bringing
in a particularly Jewish and European
notion of literature and a sensibility
about the body that could enter American
literature and change it from,
it's either waspish or
southern genteel quality.
And certainly this was
a very powerful current.
And Roth is the continuation of
that current in American letters.
Roth comes out in 1969
with Portnoy's complaint.
Portnoy is quite a novel. Um, it's
really all about masturbation.
It's about Alex Portnoy jacking off
in the bathroom to every possible a
provocative thought he can have.
And it's told as if to Alex's psychiatrist
in a sort of ranting over the top
style,
very explicit.
This got Roth into big trouble,
partly because Alex lives in a
very tight knit Jewish family.
In. This enters into the whole
story of his obsession with sex
Irving house. Uh, uh,
very prominent Jewish literary critic,
public intellectual wrote a famous essay
in 1972 called Philip Roth reconsidered
and he basically said that Roth,
the adulation given to Roth
was entirely inappropriate.
He now saw on reflection now that he
had read complaint because Roth had,
uh, an unfocused hostility
towards the Jewish community.
This enraged Roth that rage
fueled huge portions of his career
when in the human stain.
Roth has Coleman silk,
say all of Western literature
began with a coral,
the wrath of Achilles in a certain way.
He's describing his own
origin as a writer. Now.
Um, feel bear with me. Can
you do have just five minutes?
I want to get to one last point.
Yeah.
Roth in case you haven't noticed,
uh,
is a very misogynist writer.
Did you notice hard to,
hard to miss that,
why do I like Roth in this context where
writers are taken to task for their
offensiveness on cultural grounds,
on gender grounds,
on the grounds of identification?
How can you like someone who has this
major flaw who seems to see all women as
sexual objects who is unembarrassed
about saying his writing is about a man's
life. The life of men. It's
not about the life of women,
so why do I like Roth I this is
actually baffled me for years.
Why doesn't it bother me? Why
doesn't it bother me? You know,
there are parts in the human stain that
really are quite amazingly objectionable.
My favorite is the gift
of the molestation.
Do you remember this when they are talking
about Fanya and how great she is in
bed and what she's like at
breakfast afterwards and he's,
and they speculate Coleman and Nathan,
that that maybe that was the
gift of her having been molested.
Well,
molestation is never a gift.
If there's anything that comes
from living through a hard a life,
it is not the gift of the molestation,
but the gift of the person who
survived it. This is insane.
Why do I still like broth?
Well,
partly it's that like no one else.
He can take me into a voice
seamlessly draw me in.
Some of his ranting voices
are more and less convincing.
Some are more or less charactered.
Of course the women's are more
characters than the men's.
Nevertheless,
he can take me in there and the way his
sentences work are really sometimes just
astonishingly beautiful.
Okay.
There's a part in the human stain
that I particularly like. Um,
and you'll get to it as you finish the
novel for Monday and that's when he's
describing Coleman and
Fanya at Tanglewood.
So just think about that when you read
that pause for a minute over that.
I think what it is ultimately is that
I'm very moved by two things and Ross
writing that is the meditation on
mortality and what goes along with that.
I think the focus on and
the dignity of the body,
there's a very wit Manian sense to his
understanding of sex and the body in all
its complexity.
I appreciate that.
I moved by that sense of the
inaccessibility of the other person.
This was for my lecture on Monday.
The way you always get the other
fellows life somehow wrong.
That speaks to me about the difference
between my consciousness and anyone I
encounter in the world.
That to me is profound and moving.
It reminds me that for all Roth's
linguistic energy and skill as a writer,
there's still that great divide
that language is trying to cross.
And that's what I appreciate
about literature in general,
that it's that great attempt
to cross that divide.
I can overlook the massage
in e for those things.
Am I like Roth? Probably not.
But that's why I like him.
I read to see what I'm not,
not to see what I am.
Yeah.
And so Ross,
very different from me.
His misogyny is part of what allows
me to feel that I am entering,
however, partially, however,
always in a compromised way into the
consciousness of another person through
that beautiful,
amazing medium of language.
So that's why I like Roth.
And I would encourage you to think about
your own responses to the books that
we've read together.
Think about what it means
about you as a reader,
that you respond in certain ways.
So we'll pick this up on Monday.
Thank you for waiting.